INTRO.
MEANWHILE, BACK TO OUR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED PROGRAMS AS THEY TAKE
THE SCREEN BACK OVER.
McCABE ARE NO McCABE?
SCENE AND HAS NO QUESTION OF
CONTRIBUTOR'S PRETTY IS ANOTHER
ONE, SEMISURE WE CAN SHOW, BRIAN
SELTZER.
HE HAD FORMER DUKE UNIVERSITY
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROFESSOR ALAN
FRANCIS ON AND HE MADE HIS
BIZARRE CLAIM.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT BE
MORE RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE DEATHS
THAN ADOLF HITLER AND STALIN.
>> I HAVE KNOWN THOUSANDS OF
PATRONS, ALMOST ALL OF THEM AND
THEN WHILE THEY HAVE COME A LONG
MANNERED, GOOD PEOPLE.
TRUMP IS NONE OF THESE.
ONE THING TO DEAL WITH TRUMP IS
A TERRIBLE INSULT TO THE METAL
REAL AND THEY ARE PROBLEMS
STIGMA AS IT IS.
TRUMP IS AS DESTRUCTIVE AS A
PERSON IN THIS CENTURY AS
HITLER, STALIN, AND A MALWARE IN
THE LAST CENTURY.
HE MAY BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY
MORE DEATHS THAN THEY WERE.
>> Brian: IS THAT
UNBELIEVABLE?
AND HE JUST SAT THERE AND DID
NOTHING TO INTERRUPT THIS RANT.
HE SAID HE FAILED TO DO SO
BECAUSE OF TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES.
DAN BONGINO HAS NO TECHNICAL
HE SHOWS UP WITHOUT A TIE AND HE
WAS AN NYPD OFFICER FOR THE
SECRET SERVICE AND IT NOW JOINS
US AGAIN.
, SOMETIMES THERE ARE A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES AND YOU
MISSED IT BUT THAT WAS A LONG
WAY IN.
HOW DO YOU THAT PUSHBACK ON
THAT?
>> LISTEN MAN RADIO BEEN DOING
IS A LONG TIME.
YOU DON'T REALLY BELIEVE THAT,
RIGHT?
JUST TO BE CLEAR.
THAT WAS NOT A TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY.
YOU KNOW I DON'T QUESTION MY GUY
BEEN DOING THIS AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE BEEN, BUT IT'S BEEN EIGHT
YEARS.
HERE'S HOW YOU KNOW.
GO TO --
WHAT YOUR SHOW CALLED UNRELIABLE
SOURCES?
THEY CAN CALL AT RELIABLE
SOURCES, THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
MYSTERIES OF OUR TIME, HOW HIS
SHOW GOT THE TITLE RELIABLE
SOURCES.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT UNRELIABLE
GO TO THEIR TWITTER FEED AND YOU
WILL SEE THEY PROMOTED THE CLIP.
THEY PROMOTED IT.
LIKE ON THEIR TWITTER FEED.
SO IF YOU ARE HAVING AN
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY AND THIS
WAS SUCH AN EMBARRASSMENT FOR
YOUR SHOW, WHICH IT WAS, THIS A
BORING STATEMENT THIS GUY MAN
WHICH WAS REALLY HORRIBLE, YOU
WOULDN'T THINK HE WOULD GO OUT
AND PROMOTE IT YET AND WATCHED
HIS RESPONSE.
AGAIN, THIS GUY IS THE MOST
UNRELIABLE SOURCE AND WATCH WHAT
HE DOES.
HE NODS HIS HEAD, HE GOES YEAH
THIS IS TOTAL NONSENSE.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE ARE PRODUCERS
IN YOUR AREA, SOMEBODY COULD BE
TALKING RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE NOT
THERE WAS ARTIE DOES NOT, THEY
COULD GET IN YOUR EAR AND SO YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CUT THIS SHORT,
NOBODY DID OUT THERE IT'S WHAT
HE WAS HIDING IT HIDING
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS, SOMEBODY
HURT HIM BECAUSE HE WAS STILL
MERITED WHY WAS NOBODY STOPPING
THIS?
THE REASON IS, STILL TO RESIGN.
ONE MORE THING ABOUT SELTZER,
CAPTAIN UNRELIABLE, THIS IS THE
SAME GUY WHO'S BEEN CALLING OUT
AS NETWORK AND OTHER PLACES.
HE CALLED OUT MARK LIVE IN FOR
BEING A CONSPIRACY THEORIST FOR
SAYING THERE WAS A FISA WARRANT
ON TRUMPIAN HE NEVER APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
THIS GUY IS A LEAK CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS OUT THERE AND I'M
GETTING TIRED OF THIS GUY.
STU AND JAN, THANKS FOR FINDING
A SITE THAT WE HAD TO CUT THE
SHOW LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DECIDED TO LAND JUST BEFORE I
INTRODUCE YOU.
PLEASE DON'T HOLD HIM PERSONALLY
RESPONSIBLE.